[موسيقى]
تاريخيا لطالما كانت القرم في صلب نزاعات
وصراعات اقليميه منذ القدم لاهميتها
الاسراتيجيه موقع متميز يمتد من البحر
الاسود وبحر ازوف ومضيق بيرج ويعد
امتلاكها مدخل نحو مديقي العصفور والدليل
مرورا ببحر مرمره وجي وصولا الى المتوسط
تبلغ مساحه القرن 27,000 كيلو متر مربع
غالبيه سكان القرن من القوميه الروسيه
باكثر من 58% يليهم الاوكرانيون باربعه
وعشرين في المئه ثم تطار القرم ب 12%
تشكل شبه جزيره القرم كما كانت منذ قرون
اهميه استراتيجيه لروسيا بحيث انها تعد
بوابه الوحيده للمياه الدافئه على البحر
الاسود فيها مقر قياده اسطول البحر الاسود
الروسي كما ان موانئها تسمح للاسطول
الحربي الروسي بتعزيز مكانته وقدراته
العسكريه في قلب البحر الاسود ويسمح
موقعها للصواريخ الروسيه بتغطيه الجزء
الشرقي من اوروبا كاملا تمتلك شبه جزيره
القلم الثروات النفسيه وغازا طبيعيه في
منطقه البحر الاسود ووفقا لبعض تقديرات من
المتوقع ان يصل انتاجها السنوي الى نحو
سبعه ملايين من النفط